I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
there's some neurological expert talking
about the brain and talking about energy
and frequency ah and he's like his name
is Bruce Lipton he said this he's like
the Gazelle does not need to check with
the lion that it wants to eat it just
know yes because of energy is perfect
right so you can feel it and so I wonder
so I could totally feel all your loving
all the songs then because I'm I would
love to know how it works how you how a
person gravitates towards a certain
artist or a certain genre because like
growing up there's like I remember one
of my best friends like loved Smashing
Pumpkins right and I just didn't get it
they're fine they're fine
but I didn't have their albums I didn't
put him on my playlist like but they're
fine I mean I gravitated towards other
kinds of music and I loved it you know
she couldn't figure that out either so
it came to me long long time going like
there must be an energy or a frequency
or what I thought was there must be some
vibration frequency within a song that
resonates with you that was my like
thought but you probably you probably
have a better explanation that's put a
lot more elegant know I mean I can't
really explain it and I I don't think a
lot of people can explain it and I kind
of don't like to explain it you know
that's one of the greatest that's one of
the reasons I love music so much is
because my mind stops you know
everywhere else I'm just thinking so
much but when I'm playing music and I or
I'm listening to music and I'm feeling a
connection I don't need to reason about
it I don't need to like you know one of
my favorite analogies from this great
saint and NBA said you know you've come
to this you've come to this mango grove
to taste the sweetness of the mangoes
right what why do you need to know how
many trees are count how many leaves are
on each tree that's not gonna give you
the sweetness you just need to eat the
mango right it's like if you go to a
tavern
right one bottle of Danica Patrick swine
is gonna keep drunk right
you don't need definitely you don't need
to know about how many different wines
are in the cellar
maybe drunk you just need so with music
it's that thing where I don't need to
know how it works I don't care because
it's it's it's going into my heart and I
feel it you know I don't I don't care I
don't need to know you know and I think
that's one of the in my opinion one of
the problems I think with like Western
culture especially here in the West is
because we're so obsessed with
explaining we want an answer for
everything they want to answer for
absolutely and the things that we can't
explain we push away because they scare
us because we really control them it
says let me feel like when we can
explain things oh we have a sense of
control over this thing we understand
this thing we understand how it works
right I said but the things that we
can't understand we ignore and I just
think it's a shame because those are the
things that really can affect us the
deepest I think affect our hearts the
deepest you know you know we try to
explain love so much you're like this a
NAPA like the true essence of love I
mean how can you put that in words you
can't
[Music]